so I had to do press in Cleveland and I
went on this like morning radio show you
know ever this lady who's a dime piece
and before I went on there like you know
we've had some other comets on here dude
this [ __ ] guy and Bobby Lee's
interview that when they're doing press
will make your day it's so funny they
don't want to be there and because I
don't want to be there either
wait do you see this I eat it chin go to
this the comic ooh it's so funny cuz
doing press yeah how light this guy's my
spirit animal this morning doing press
cuz you can tell you song over its live
and it's [ __ ] keep going I say this
guy's my spirit animal and then there's
a link keep going keep it moving should
be keep going my voice don't keep going
it could be at tweets and replies right
wherever all my [ __ ] that dude this is
the front page yeah but uh yeah let me
do this it's so funny
it's the greatest I would have bought
his tickets should have all sold out in
the lady so she don't know what to do
she doesn't know what to do
[Music]
what day did you do it I would have done
on Friday now I see it
keep going Jenna to be on there and all
the comics well there it is this yeah
okay Marc Marc Norman welcome back to a
nudie Cleveland it is time for a little
bit of a laugh we need computer live so
be here at hilarities this weekend so
welcome here into the studio it's good
to have ya it's a pleasure
I'm a little hungover a little gay but
life here with you sister
I appreciate you saying that I'm very
happy to be here with your toes
all right sorry hiding my erection yeah
great I know you just loves Lyman
yeah that's Lyman so I'm really gonna be
on the toilet later boy best corned beef
and in the Midwest if you ask me it's
delicious it's the size of your head
yeah yeah and I ain't weighed too much
but at least everybody there was very
attractive no I'm kidding good good good
grub there
oh yeah bet you are yeah I've been
farting it up in the grease the door was
a little shut yeah we're a little
smaller green room exactly have we
called hotboxing really soaking it all
in is it the smell of your own farts for
something this is live beautiful EMU
farted to be weird but if I fart I'm
good guy thing you could hear no woman
would ever say something like that no it
is more of maybe a queefing you know oh
sorry
you know you've had your coffee your
master who knows so yeah we're all
adults here you live you City now but
you're from New Orleans yeah well well
done you're a grinder by looking you up
yes yeah but I know that we're talking
about clean one sports here but I know
for you guys and your Saints that was ah
I'm sorry I know that was that was
brutal we really thought we had it you
know New Orleans all we do is drink and
go to strip clubs we really needed this
win you know but no dice right there so
close yeah always next year right yes
but we get one of these every you know
censure have you seen it's been enormous
so you live in New York now that was
what yeah it's worse did you just
recently move in with a lovely lady I
bought a place I got a delay I moved in
with a lady in Alexa oh yeah yeah she's
a track of everything and she gets mad
when I talked to Siri yeah bought my
place I have a piece of the rock in
Manhattan it's the only thing my parents
have been proud of that I've done I've
done The Tonight Show Conan Colbert
Comedy Central but when I bought my
apartment that's when they actually
started answering my phone calls but hey
that's why I'm a comedian cuz I gotta
get love somewhere so but I mean you're
just so getting into this business
oh yeah 35 not that young but uh you
know not on the viagra yet where am I
but snort it I like to snort it said
quicker [ __ ] awesome he's in New York
I love this dude yes please don't you
love them ah I went down a whole rabbit
watching oh dude I went down a rabbit
hole watching on a stand up
I'm so sad watching fun of course it's a
sad day now go to Bobbie Lee where she's
a savage it's all your same thing no I
didn't post biologies really but I
posted that when Mark Norman's my spirit
animal do impress this morning I his
that and then they said the hilarity
goes make sure watch Bobby Lee's and
then tag the lady and the ladies
actually really cool about the host yeah
she's super hey it wouldn't be all Bobby
Lee's profile where would it be on
YouTube bro
Oh chin talking opposed totally hung in
there though where do you see what Bobby
Lee I'm surprised you didn't get in
trouble for this yeah do Bobby Lee yep
there you go there it is second sucks
yes a year old yep okay so he want to
post your never clean and proper okay to
have a girlfriend the questions getting
uncomfortable ask the questions do your
job Natalie thing what what is it
Natalie I like you you use white strips
be honest real they can be real if I
lived in Cleveland you and I yeah and
boys but thank you hold our you know I'm
86 confidence and I have this um I just
want to go for it your own ring and look
at her
it never works no she doesn't like
ethnics no so does that mean if this is
not in the morning yes working out those
things it doesn't feel like it is no
yeah your energy is like it's a little
too strong I have a relationship yes
yours going really good
really yeah how long have you been
together for years and strong it's
really strata and she's way better than
you
she's I've never seen him before I did
let me just tell you this did come off I
don't care always do they always come on
no I don't live in trumps America I live
in my own America and I'm gonna get
naked then fine he's done America how
funny is that he's amazing he's so funny
how he kills me that mark Normand though
oh my god dude you go to Vegas I know
sorry my nose or am I like to snort it
kicks in faster she goes you look good
eos black don't crack
okay that was the best one she's so
great that she she's awesome
there's the boss and every like yeah
every comic goes to her and there's a
whole loop of comics with her it's fun
why would I give that to you as it's a
gift it's a gift it's a gift